boy is it amazing over there yes China
got a leapfrog America in terms of
self-driving because they have the
ability for the government to make
superfast decisions that's what people
tell me I'm not sure about that is
definitely a very efficient
decision-making process and there's
absolutely strong support from the
government side yeah for my
understanding I think that's very
helpful for the industry yeah
so you think it'll happen they're faster
it's moving absolutely very fast but you
know there's also a lot of other things
advantages that Silicon Valley and other
places have tell us like the talents and
the AI and also infrastructure there's a
bunch of other advantages Connor
show us another exciting video I found
these videos fascinating and you can hit
the pause button when you see something
interesting in the video and I have the
questions I was gonna ask you queued up
as well but I feel like when we watch
these videos we're going by them a
little bit faster I want to pause on one
of them and you can tell us what's going
on here so here we are we're going down
a street we see a bunch of a 3d model of
the world including down to the trees
and the leaves right this is this is a
3d reconstruction of the streets we
created you can see clearly see the
color on the ground and it's actually a
3d model we drive the street up and up
and down couple times and then we can
create this then we can view it from any
angle
we like to and you do this with one of
those cars with all the sensors on it
right got it we use a bare minimum set
of sensors to make this kind of amount
and what it what is the detail level
that you need to create a map that is
capable of being safer than a human do
you feel we've already done that are we
already safer than humans so I don't
think the self-driving car system is
safe so it's depending on which which
one you're talking to right there's a
plaintiff company working on this we are
we're not making the whole thing we're
just making the mapping analyzation
piece it's a very
Pease but it's not everything we needed
the whole thing to work very tightly and
you have enough redundancy at every
level to guarantee the safety of a
self-driving car system other
redundancies key so if you lose GPS or
if you lose a camera still works not
doing anything crazy the car is still
running or you know safely handle this
kind of situation and what's gonna
happen in the future if we're all
sleeping in our car and it loses a
camera at the same time that a GPS
signal goes out for some reason what
will happen you alarm will go off to
take over it just pulls over to the side
of road and flashes its flashers what is
the protocol you think I believe that
you eventually there will be remote
controllers of operators of this vehicle
team emergency and human interference is
necessary when situations happens so
something unexpected happens and you'll
basically hit an alarm will go off and
in some boiler room there'll be a
hundred driver sitting there taking over
and saying this is your a remote driver
everything's gonna be fine I'm pulling
you over to the next Starbucks would you
like a latte like it's gonna be that
simple it's it's probably not that
similar to that I think it's like
basically you this is like my
imagination so we have a car actually
not working and you know it's pulled
over and the remote control we will try
to jumpy and figure out what's what went
wrong or maybe they'll send another car
come over and pick up the cup you or the
stuff